a tough endurance test it's part of a
study being carried out by detail like
he's looking at how risk factors like a
sedentary lifestyle and obesity impact
physical fitness
then it'll be two minutes three two one
great two minutes that's something the
sports physician hasn't seen often he's
tested more than 20,000 boys and girls
between the ages of 6 and 25 we've
observed that the target group of people
who don't do sports or don't exercise
regularly generally don't really push
their bodies to the limit that makes it
very tough to acquire hard data to
acquire unbiased information about the
entire population the researchers have
examined people from a cross-section of
society test subjects come from schools
companies and among job seekers the
researchers measure body fat skin fold
thickness and the risk for obesity at
least the sports professionals like him
in the comparison group do well
participants have to answer a series of
questions do they smoke or drink how
often do the exercise the researchers
found that risk factors rise from the
age of 16 upwards only 1/4 of the young
adults they surveyed lead healthy
lifestyles and education levels seem to
play a crucial role in health
consciousness this athlete has the
muscle power as well as stamina that
other people his age often lock after
they begin working young adults usually
have little time for sports and before
long their fitness level falls
significantly it doesn't matter which
risk factor we're talking about as soon
as one appears you have to reckon with a
significant loss of fitness and each
additional risk factor leads to a
further decline in performance it's the
cap which can measure brainwaves shows
which regions are active in the brain at
any given moment Stefan Schneider wants
to use it to find out whether exercise
can improve mental fitness as well the
researcher tested the hypothesis with a
third grade class on the first day the
kids began their day at school with
sports later they took a test
on another day they only took the test
and performed much worse
that's because exercise reduces stress
in brain regions involved in thought gun
sunshine is even that's it's very
decisive that the areas of the brain
associated with strong cognitive
function are simply slowed down through
exercise sports make demands on very
specific areas in the brain primarily
the motor cortex in the motor cortex
there's a change in activity which means
that activity is not taking place in
other areas and then so they can simply
rest and relax Amanda Wilson so sports
can contribute in a big way not only to
physical fitness but to mental health as
well and that at any age as studies on
marathon runners have shown even a few
years of regular training can
dramatically improve mental and physical
fitness levels among older people and
the good news is that even a bit of
exercise is better than none the human
body it seems reacts positively to
nearly any kind of physical activity
and it's never too late to start